you know it was very funny when we did
the the pilot for flash when they asked
me to come back is harry henry allen you
know uh barry's
father wrongly convicted of killing his
mother in front of a ten-year-old barry
you know which was not my origin story
in 1990 right brothers for cbs at all so
that was just a role i would want to do
whether i had never been
barry allen or not but having been barry
allen it brought those things
together you know it's like you talk
about being in the moment being close to
who you really are because
it was a unique situation i was playing
his father
i had done this
role
he knew i had played the role
i knew what he was taking on maybe what
some of his hopes and dreams and
insecurities might be
and so
there were times in those beautifully
written scenes
between henry and barry
uh in the in the uh
prison in iron heights that
you know i didn't know if
henry was talking to barry
or if old flash was talking to new flash
or if john was talking to grant
and when those things all come together
yeah it's it's really done but those
scenes i can watch and go they will
always be among my favorite that's great
that's a great feeling too do you do you
look back and think
god you know if we had the producers or
the
just the knowledge we have now and you
know if we had different
producers or designers or whatever it is
for the flash of 1990 when you were
there
this could have been something big and
and also how did you deal with that
disappointment it only lasted a year
right
yeah yeah yeah yeah well we had it all
we were the most expensive show warner
brothers had ever done for television oh
wow at that point it was a high-tech
suit designed by
oscar winner you know bob short and
built
um
and our writing was great danny wilson
and paul demaio were excellent i mean we
had uh howard chaikin
as the story editor we had
uh i i don't even want to start naming
because we had so many
great and talented people and we were
nominated for an emmy for art direction
right when we did a big lot premiere on
the back lot for the international press
our reviews were through the roof i mean
washington post new york time i mean the
big louisville courier journal
you know and they talked about the
acting and they talked about the art
direction and they talked about at the
time
state of the art effects right for
television and so
we were a creative and industry
hit
now
it was the hardest thing i have ever
done i mean we would start at 7 a.m
monday morning and work till 10 or 11 at
night come in 10 11 at tuesday and uh
work till two in the afternoon on
wednesday come in at two and so by
wednesday or thursday we were shooting
all night by saturday we were blacking
in the back line at warner brothers to
shoot day for night and then we were
back in at 7 00 a.m monday morning um
and you're in everything you're in every
day i mean you're the flash
i mean our transportation department
whenever i thought i had it bad i'd look
at you know the fact that they were they
were having 25 26 hour days i mean our
overtime
was through the roof and we were already
budgeted
um so
at by the time we did that through the
third week in august through the second
week in may with five days off for four
days off for christmas and that was it
because we had to do mostly live action
practical effects we didn't have the cgi
capability
then that we have now and so it was
hours and hours and hours and danny and
paul were uncompromising
they wanted to do the show that they
wanted to see
and so
i can look at it today and i can
appreciate i can appreciate the fact
that the technology has come it's 30
years later one would hope
and i think what i was saying i think
what i meant to say was why didn't the
stars align for that project and now
that hearing you say all this you know
all you had all these great components
of it so why didn't succeed has to be
even more disappointing now you're like
you know it just was it was
revered it was all these things so what
was it
well as a combination of things i think
number one
it was 30 years ago putting on a
superhero
costume in 1990 was very different from
putting on a superhero costume in 2014
from the new cw show
we were like
i was hesitant to even audition for it
because i had been on broadway in new
york i had my two daytime emmys i had
you know i had fashioned myself a series
and i thought
only superhero reference i had
was being spoofed at that point and i
just didn't think that that was where
my talent lay and then april webster i'm
sure you know grip multiple emmy award
winning caster director said john just
read the script that's all i ask
and then i i read it and there were all
these human values there was the
unblessed son
of a cop family in which real cops
worked the streets but i had gone into
the crime lab so that my mom didn't have
to worry that all of her men
might not come home that night my older
brother was the street cop who my dad
loved and my dad was always putting me
down so
bear my berry was the unblessed son
you know in the family who gets these
superpowers and his first reaction is i
don't want to know from this i have no
uh desire to be a hero i have no
pretensions to be a hero i have settled
for my lot in life and that's the deal
until his brother's killed
and then it's like okay it's on and then
he has all this ability that he knows
his dad
it would make his dad so proud
but he can't tell him
so there was a i'm starting to feel it
you know by about that point right and
then they promised me we will not put
you in a pair of red tights
i came to kind of regret that later
because that suit was
so hot
it was i'd be in it for 20 minutes and
you could wring me out but i don't want
to
you know the last thing people want to
hear is
those of us who've been fortunate enough
to play these
iconic characters yeah sit around and
whine about our suits right right right
but uh there were there were challenges